[Musique]
donc à tous
c'est une version pour le moins
revisitée d'une conférence de presse
présidentielle
malibu qu'elle est à la tête du salvador
depuis 2010 9 ne se refuse aucun
artifice pour promouvoir son cheval de
bataille le bitcoin la première des
crypto monnaie fondé en 2009
alexandre le grand est est en train de
conquérir le monde ils font des parts ou
d alexandrie alors je me suis dit si on
veut que le bitcoin conquiert le monde
on devrait construire d alexandrie et
pourquoi pas construire la première ici
au salvador
le bitcoin monnaie officielle du
salvador depuis septembre dernier au
même titre que le dollar
c'est ici que l'histoire a commencé il
ya deux ans elles ont été un tout petit
village le premier à avoir surfé sur la
crypto monnaie
quand rentrée a créé l'application
bitcoin beach avec ses associés
là je n'ai pas de mots nés sur moi alors
pour la payer j'utilise son code qr que
je scanne
son nom apparaît j'en dis que la
quantité et voilà
le message vient de lui envoyer 180 $
aux beach boys
hot dog soda ou recherches téléphoniques
ici tout peut être payé par ce biais
pour mettre un peu d'argent de côté
d'argent quand on reçoit un bitcoin on
n'y touche pas on ne laisse fakty fier
maintenant on a enfin une possibilité d'
épargne dans le village les gens se crée
un petit pécule et n'ont pas besoin
d'aller à la banque ou de faire la queue
et si vous pensiez encore que les crypto
monnaie était l'apanage des nouvelles
générations
j'ai été la première à accepter le
bitcoin chez mama rosa on cuisine encore
au feu de bois mais on paie sa note en
argent numérique en vérité au début
personne ne savait ce que c'était mais
on nous a expliqué que c'était une
monnaie virtuelle
j'ai acheté deux vaches à ça n'aurait
pas été possible sans le bitcoin
mais dès qu'on sort des lentes et le
bitcoin est plutôt tombé à plat car
naïve bouquet les c'est une main de fer
sous un look de hipster et le secteur
privé déplore que la petite révolution
monétaire était élancé sans aucune
consultation et à marche forcée
les trois mois qui ont séparé l'annnonce
de la mise en pratique on était
complètement chaotique est le
gouvernement ne nous disait rien et par
dessus le marché nous menacer en nous
disant que tous les commerçants il
devait être prêt à utiliser le bitcoin
70 il voulait dire développer les
logiciels investir et former les gens
à passer stationnaire décision
expéditive système mal sécurisé des
milliers de cas de fraude par
l'application chivot wallet lancé par le
gouvernement malgré les 30 dollars en
crédits bitcoin offert à tous les
salvadoriens le soufflé est vite retombé
en mars 86% des entreprises affirmé
n'avoir encore jamais fait de
transactions crypto monnet à saint ségal
la deuxième ville du pays c'est la
monnaie papier qui règne encore
le gouvernement a donné les 30 dollars
j'ai téléchargé l'application mais après
les avoir dépensé je ne vais plus et
ulysse et
une population peu enthousiaste mais le
maire will salgado c'est que la nouvelle
monnaie a un grand avantage
les transactions sont instantanées sans
frais et sans impôts
une aubaine pour tous ceux qui vivent
des ré messas cet argent envoyé par les
membres de leur famille parti travailler
aux états unis
les messages sont indispensables à la
santé du commerce ici c'est comme
l'essence de notre moteur
qui avez vous envoyé là haut pour qu'on
leur envoie de l'argent
et tais toi
vous voyez impossible de trouver
quelqu'un qui n'est pas de la famille
aux etats-unis
laoura reçois des messages de son frère
en bitcoin par le biais de l'application
elle peut ensuite les convertir en
dollars dans des centres agréés
avant on devait payer des frais d'envoi
mais avec cette application c'est
complètement gratuit
si les habitants ne plébiscitent pas
encore l'expérience pour des centaines
d'adeptes du bitcoin le pays devenu la
terre promise d'une nouvelle ère
va consister la monnaie officielle en
australie on perd beaucoup d'argent on
taxe canton convertino bitcoin
bitcoin est le bitcoin c'est l'avenir
les monnaies traditionnelles au dollar
la livre qui leur valeur va s'effondrer
attirer les touristes et les
investisseurs occidentaux alors que des
dizaines de milliers de salvadoriens
fuient chaque année la pauvreté et la
violence en sens inverse c'est le
paradoxe d'un pays qui cherchent une
nouvelle voie de développement